hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today i'm just about to
start playing the marvel avengers beta
on the playstation 4.
this game has like completely eluded me
uh you would have thought
that an avengers game made by crystal
dynamics and published by square enix
would be exactly what i would want in
life
but when i first saw it i was really
uninterested and then kind of tuned out
everything else related to it after that
point sadly
and then i realized it's coming out next
month and there's a beta right now and i
was like oh my god i expected this to be
a 2021 game
what is happening but i guess i also
just don't really know what it's trying
to do
i feel like it's maybe trying to be
anthemy whatever let's get to it point
being i don't know what to expect
um and i am curious but
feel like i'm maybe not gonna love it
are you serious dude
no i don't want to do that it's already
a lot of advertising
so there's that thank you oh my god
that's the worst and no game should ever
make me do that again i already hate it
you've lost me already i'm sorry
this is too many pop-ups why have you
why have you done any of this this is
okay look i said that i was a little bit
concerned
but now i think i've been advertised to
like five times and been told that i
have to sign up with my email address
uh and my birthday so
just let's just go play beta let's just
play
cool normal sounds good to me i'm a fan
[ __ ] hell you know that old saying
never meet your heroes yeah i do
well
i did okay
and it was awesome
the avengers were everything i imagined
they looked like close-ish to the active
counterparts but not quite cause that'd
be expensive it is really strange
okay
the bridge see now i'm excited though
because i get to play as
thor which sounds like it should be the
best
um i mean not that i haven't played
members of the avengers in various other
video games but
oh that's not up to the start i
quite wanted
see that feels pretty good
there's a dodge mechanic i like a good
dodge mechanic
a heavy attack let's do it if we can get
to him
it really makes you feel like the war
we got civilians trapped behind those
barricades understood
nice nice nice
today for a reason okay
oh you need help hello sir how to hold a
square
are you hurt this feels really arcadey
um lucky for you i am my team which i'm
okay with
but
it it feels like one of those mini games
that you play when you're doing a um
what are they called there's like
virtual reality room experiences
where it's like very heavily scripted
and
really small areas like this is very
very closed and there isn't exactly that
much
um variety for me
i mean that's cool i love some
verticality but it's also maybe it's
like hard to
to go to playing a game like this after
just recently
um playing uh the start of spider-man
again
because like that gives you that that
superhero vibe so well
okay i mean
i'm a big fan of the design this is cool
i also like how far away they fly be
fair to that
um okay it's just a heavy attack i'm
gonna break a shield
yeah dundal way shields now [ __ ]
okay we can use the heroic blast again
is that this
do i take damage i'm not entirely sure
okay another cutscene cool great
hey get back here
okay this is so different
to tomb raider let me tell you this is
fine again though it feels like
something that i would play at disney
world
you know like like it just feels so on
rails in a really
strange way
like i'm just in the prologue right now
but how does this work when it's
multiplayer i wonder if it's this
scripted
are you both in the scripted segments i
guess i'll just have to play more at
some points
okay let's see how this feels
yes i have played marvel vs capcom
fire's a nice touch you just killed a
lot of people
tony stark oh i like that you can fly
whenever you want to
we'll keep you updated
should you need from the sky can i do
that oh that's that's
it's very cool another cutscene
i guess it's more of a cinematic but
still damn
i can't not hear nolan north in every
single thing
that he says it just is the most
knowledge nolan north
i love nolan but he's broken a few video
games for me at this point
what do you mean did i leave combat are
you sure about that
i'm just trying to make my way to the
second one which i'm going to punch with
my bare fists
well not quite bad it is
that ship's not ready for flight why is
it moving someone's initiated the
security protocols
the chimera's autopilot has taken over
you'll need backup
we're heading back negative secure the
bridge laura bailey really got the whole
squad
really about the whole squad you're up
bruce
i feel like he's the one that looks like
the most like mark ruffalo like he
really does
the hair stands out so much okay i'm
excited to play as hulk
this should be this should be a good
time
even if i'm not loving how scripted it
is
yes yes you mad we know we know okay let
me punch
oh i grabbed him okay slams you grab and
then you slam
man i just i feel very murderous
um i really feel like i'm literally
killing people
he doesn't feel heavy this is it's again
arcady in a way that i did not expect it
to feel
um
which is like okay if i i still i'm not
entirely sure we'll see when we get
there
uh maybe i'll stream some of the later
parts of this the beta
okay oh that was pretty neat
um but the the reason that like a game
like destiny which is so
can be so repetitive in that it
literally involves you doing the exact
same thing in the exact same place in a
lot of cases the reason it works is
because the gameplay is
really good um in the combat itself but
you know
there are issues with the systems that i
i understand
people have i get where that all comes
from
oh there you go but the combat itself is
smooth as hell this combat
is is not enough to want to get me to
keep fighting through these kinds of
environments you know
like often i feel like i'm hitting
nothing
those tanks are doing a number on the
bridge it could fall if we don't take
them out
hurry up big guy can't take much more
punishment
thunderclap you say all right
see it's all very cool these are cool
effects
i'm not denying any of that bringing in
the quintet
okay um
yeah they suddenly put a lot of effort
into those cinematics
it just doesn't necessarily feel good
or it feels very passive like i'm not
really
that involved in what's happening even
though i'm literally
those weapons were meant for the good
guys matt do you read
[Applause]
oh no nice cap nice
good at least it's giving me a feel of
how literally everyone controls right
from the jump
oh oh that's actually pretty good
which i feel like i say every time it's
actually very cool in the way that
it is planned out but
continues to feel like an arcade game
which is very weird
okay let's do it i know doc they're
trying to hijack the chimera
all right that block feels it looks like
i'm holding a tin but that's cool
does not feel or sound very nice
i really like the aerial combat like the
way that it looks but um again it's like
you're basically competing with
spider-man where that's concerned and
it's
a very hard act to follow this is also
just maybe too easy but maybe that's
that's just
you know because it's the prologue it's
the tutorial
all right i need an update i need an
update the reactor won't stabilize
his molecular structures breaking down
it into a cast
huge bubble feeding energy into the
reactor sometimes it'll happen
it's extraordinary it's a nice touch
no i like that
there you go nice good walk cap
again that was cool
i guess my calm is a down cap if i've
noticed it seems really dumb that you
haven't
got
brooklyn
avengers cool is transporting a highly
lethal sonic disrupter bomb
our enemies intend to detonate it within
the city
that's not good we're going down sonic
disrupter bomb
oh my god those are bad
i feel like this would have been really
expensive like
that is an entrance looking at these
cutscenes and all the lighting
the light effects in general the
explosions
i feel like this would have cost a lot
and taken a lot of time to make
they definitely put a lot of work in
here that's for sure
task master
it's really funny to hear seeing someone
say task mask in a sinister way because
it's such a silly game
i mean we need to get that detonated oh
boy
oh that oh there goes the bridge
also for the record this bridge is a lot
louder than that i don't know if you
ever been on this bridge
it's windy and noisy out there
okay let's do it
seriously again it feels like katie but
a lot of a lot of work put in here i i'm
not gonna
take that away from them i recognize
that
i feel like they've made this bridge
very long too
really elongated it for the purposes of
this
yep just keep punching them
nice good stuff i'll take this
okay cool we did it look at us go
got it it is oh he's a blocky boy huh
you've been doing a lot of blocks out
here
it doesn't look like he's blocking any
of it strangely definitely looks like
i'm
absolutely shooting him
that was very repetitive too damn okay
he's got you there why is he even
staying why wouldn't he just peace out
now
you think he'd be like you know what i'm
good i got exactly what i want let me
leave
oh target that is a thing that i want
right thank you
okay this is so repetitive you gotta
have more moves than this dude
he also just doesn't really react while
standing there
he does look cool though i like the
design like he's
it sounds like he's screaming but he
doesn't
really seem to care very much about
what's happening to him
your dance ends now cool
grapple counter press all 2ds widows
grapple counter
to counter attacks with blue yellow
indicators got it okay
cool
that's pretty sweet cool throat must be
frustrating
he's not great at this i don't think
that looked cool
i feel like i'm just getting repetitive
at this point
there are some things that i'm into for
the most part
i'm not particularly enjoying this um
but i do respect the cinematics
that was scripted for sure and this
smells like distraction
i'm done talking l1 to activate veil of
shadows
okay i thought you'd never ask neat
pretty cool
next time take better notes
yeah dundal wrecked this bridge seems
like it's holding
its structural integrity together pretty
well frankly bomb deactivated all right
we did it kids game over all credits
you think you've won what the hell are
you talking about
look around romanov the world will
remember this day
damn the day their heroes failed them
i like her outfit too i'd wear that
nice pants nice pants not that different
to these pants
steve can you hear me get the hell out
of there
screw this
well those two can fly we can't all fly
you know
what does that mean
for everyone
cool lanyards you guys very nice i don't
know why you how you could even be upset
with a landing that cool dangerous
untested technology causing damage on an
unprecedented scale
okay our beloved captain america was
killed during the attempted theft of
this technology this looks cool
thousands of
other innocent people died and many more
still bear the scars of what has come to
be known
as a day i like the style hundreds fell
sick
encased in strange cocoons only
generally
dangerous otherworldly powers with no
known cure
the disease has spread across the
country and while both shield
and the avengers promise to rectify the
situation really pretty but
generally if you have to explain
something this way you [ __ ] up a bit
you so-called heroes
transformed san francisco into an
infectious
gas-filled quarantined zone you unleash
diseased powerful beings that wreak
havoc throughout our nation
many still so i
ask you again dr banner do the avengers
pose a danger to society
yes their activities outlawed the once
mighty heroes disbanded but out of
tragedy
is born hope after the government
liquidation of stark industries
doctor george this is not a good way to
present a player within a month
and founders even though it's mechanics
think
science is the solution to our nature
you should have done this way more
organically
in gameplay somewhere maybe that's just
my preference other people might like
this and obviously i'm talking over it
which is going to drive you
nuts but i can promise you this
if you'd like to just see the cutscene
itself i'm sure that's up on the
internet
by itself we'll find a cure for the
inhuman disease
and then it does this as well
i'm gonna leave it there which is such a
weird place to leave it i know this is
just my first impressions based on this
this prologue
i know this game is much bigger than
this i'll probably stream more of the
beta
in the coming weeks or whatever i'm
alana i will see you guys next time